welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian Chapter seven the reckoning
in which mando reconnects with most of
the crew he's met this season and they
all respond you son of a [ __ ] I'm in
and we were left with a heartbreaking
cliffhanger for the family but also
possibly a center for the rise of
Skywalker well I'll explain all the
major details that you might have missed
from this episode and spoiler warning if
you haven't seen it yet okay the episode
opens with mando on the razor crest have
you know your or Abeche you know that
that text translates to incoming comma
which I guess you also could have gotten
from the contacts because of you he's
getting a call here later the screen
translates to autopilot which yeah you
also could have gotten from the context
shut up mandos former guild leader grief
carga offers to clear his record if he
takes out Verna her songs client
character obviously this plan stinks of
trap theory Mon Calamari but man who
agrees and returns to tour gun perhaps
supports who recruit Kara dune Kara's
mid-fight with a zamorak these same
species at small notice the horns and
the tattoos this tethered fight is a
parallel conjoined test of strength that
Kara will later compete with mando on
when they arm wrestle and her
overpowering this AB rack here sets up
how dramatic it is when later she loses
the arm wrestling against mando due to
babyoh de force choking her on the crest
mando lets Kara pick from his armory and
she snatches a thermal detonator grenade
a like an apple we never see her use it
so I'm guessing that she'll whip out
this thing in some surprise moment in
the finale episode maybe to escape mouth
kid Ian and all those troops to KITT
will never be safe until he hip is dead
baby Yoda
spider-man's down to listen in on this
and notice how right after this the
crest nearly crashes as baby Otis steers
the joystick wildly is the kid just
plain or is this another example of how
baby o2 understands a lot more than we
think and knows it's a bad idea to head
back to the imperial territory so it's
desperately trying to steer them away
but before we continue think you do bang
energy for sponsoring this episode every
can a bang is 16 ounces that's right no
wimpy 12 ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it's sugar-free
and as zero calories yet it tastes great
with over 20 flavors to choose from one
of those flavors is star blasts
it is sweet its unassuming drunk already
unfeeling jazzed I feel like a star and
I feel blast I got no regrets
look there are mornings when I was up
late the night before writing a full
movie breakdown and I'm just like really
dragging but a can a bang energy helps
pick me up so I can starve blast through
more work we check out bang on Instagram
that can be you and even get 20% off
your order at bang energy calm when you
use the code new rockstars 25 there you
can get a variety 12 back with a dozen
their flavors flavors like sour pina
colada
cotton candy rainbow unicorn I have no
idea what a rainbow unicorn should taste
like but I bet it's magical thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this
breakdown get 20% off at bang energy com
using the code at new rocks there's 25
and follow the adventure of bang on
instagram at bang energy CEO the next
crew member mando needs is a babysitter
bringing him back to our vollis 7 to the
blurred ranch of his ignite friend
Cahuilla AKA pig Nolte much I think it
might be a strand cast I don't think it
was engineered I've worked in the gene
farms that's what's sad to find some
terms here a strand cast is a new Star
Wars term presumably slang for
genetically engineered being or clone
strand may be referring to like a DNA
strand and cast for how they're outcasts
to society we have speculated that
cloning may be making a comeback in the
Star Wars universe with a Kamino patch
visible on dr. Pershing and previous
episodes and theories that Palpatine in
the rise of Skywalker
could have returned via cloning
technology Khalil's rationale is that
baby yoda is too ugly to have been
genetically engineered how dare you Pig
multi also that clones are designed to
age faster the opposite of old baby odor
there that doesn't necessarily rule out
cloning though Boba Fett was a clone of
Jango Fett without sped up aging and you
wouldn't clone Yoda just for his looks
you'd clone him to get another [ __ ]
Yoda but the fact that this episode
brought up genetic engineering at all is
significant maybe something to keep in
mind heading into the rise of Skywalker
kuil reveals that he scavenged the
assassin droid IG 11 and reprogrammed
him with domestic functions he says that
he did so under the Charter of the New
Republic suggesting that the New
Republic
struggling to rewrite the laws post
Empire and is starting with simple codes
like Finders Keepers there's an extended
montage showing quills humorous
retraining of IG 11 some fun VFX details
like frogs hopping out of the trough
when he pours in the feed in IG 11
lightly kicking away a lizard so he
doesn't crush it queel states only does
this line serve to chip away at mandos
bias against droids it also parallels
mandos rearing of baby yoda who in the
next scene reveals itself as not an
inherently good jedi type but also a
danger capable of sith moves like like a
four-stroke all you guys still feel good
about those baby oda tattoos when mando
says she's a friend notice a baby Odin
nods its head no the fact that the
killer ID 11 can be taught kindness
stresses how crucial it is to teach
empathy to this living child Coyle said
that he heard rumors about the stuff
from his time as a slave for the Empire
yeah no kidding in the Empire Strikes
Back Vader averaged one four choke per
meeting Coyle says that he was a slave
for three human lifetimes meaning he
must have been a slave before the Empire
they meet up with grief and his other
bounty hunters on the lava fields of
Navarro at night they're attacked by
these winged creatures which could be
the pterosaurs
sake a sorors from legends or maybe the
root beings from the Clone Wars animated
series native to the planet Onderon and
used as war beasts in mouse after
attempting to heal mando in a previous
episode baby Yoda now helps grief and
introduces a new ability to the official
Star Wars Canon force healing video to
both heals the flesh wound and rids the
poison from his body this would have
come in handy with qui-gon
afterwards grief changes as planned to
double-cross mando and suddenly shoots
his other men and notice how his quick
draw surprises even mando and Cara like
if he wanted to shoot them they would
not have seen that coming
the new plan is to cuff mando in
disguise him as a prisoner similar to
the plan to cuff chewy in a new hope and
they get in past stormtroopers on
speeder bikes and they meet with Verna
Herzog's character who brings up the
history between the Mandalorians the
Rise of the Empire why
did Mandalore resist our expansion the
Empire improves every system it touches
improves every system it touch it look I
know it's a bit murky who's in charge
since the Empire collapse but it's odd
for the client to be speaking about the
Empire in present tense
maybe his loyalty is made in delusional
or maybe he's still connected with some
efforts to keep fragments of the Empire
intact and secret but Herzog gets a call
from his boss Moff Gideon Giancarlo
Esposito Gus fring for Breaking Bad and
better call Saul he hints that they
actually don't have the child and then
blaster fire tears through the joint
killing the clients and making is brief
his name in a bit ironic now look
outside I see nothing but death and
chaos these shooters are death troopers
first introduced flanking Admiral critic
and wrote one but never utilized that
much
notice how the barrels of their rifles
are charred the paint seared off a
blaster fire behind them dozens of storm
troopers arrive from an Imperial troop
transport shuttle and notice that unlike
the stormtroopers we've seen so far in
the Mandalorian these ones have clean
armor suggesting a segment of the Empire
that hasn't wallowed in - dusty
desperate irrelevance these guys shower
and behind them arrives Moff Gideon in a
TIE fighter that makes an epic landing
its wings folding in they fall now they
fold now we haven't seen ties do this
before this appears to be based on
leftover concept art that Lucas Films
Doug Chang designed for the force
awakens and in a heartbreaking
cliffhanger the speeder bikes intercept
baby Yoda leaving behind the corpse of
pig Nolte hopefully IG 11 left behind on
the crest will swoop and rescue them and
maybe soften mandos hatred of droids or
even better maybe odo could just grab
the steering controls of the speeder
bike just like how we did on the crest
comment down below with your thoughts on
this episode follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vas and subscribe to new
rock stars - breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for watching
[Music]